hospitals are empty homeless shelters
are empty coronavirus cases aren't
spiking great news right not according
to the mainstream media which is hard at
work inventing fake problems to frighten
us then the high school science
experiment that locked down the world
Joe Biden's new nickname for president
trump spoiler alert it's super lame and
an explosive new allegation that Norma
McCorvey
the pro-abortion plaintiff in Roe vs.
Wade
faked her pro-life Christian conversion
all that and more I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Joe Biden he just can't take his foot
out of his mouth he never seems able to
do that we'll get to all of that in a
moment because we haven't spent nearly
enough time on the 2020 race which most
people forgot is even happening I would
like to know though in the comments
section of all the thousands of Joe
Biden gaffes foot-in-mouth dumb comments
over the many decades he's been in
politics which is your favorite which is
your favorite Biden gaffe please let me
know there's so many to choose from it's
a veritable buffet of buffoonery but I
have to tell you before we get to Joe
about my favorite fake problem because
you know there are a lot of real
problems obviously there's this epidemic
that's going around the world there's
this huge lockdown economic devastation
30 40 million people thrown out of work
so all these all these real problems
caused by hysteria and alarmism but the
left keeps moving the goal posts so
initially the problem was there is not
we don't know anything about the virus
now we do know things about the virus
then the problem was we're not locking
down fast enough well we locked down the
entire country then it was we and people
are buying masks which was bad then it
was people are not buying masks which is
bad then it was we don't have enough
testing now we've got an even bigger
problem no one wants to take the test
we didn't have enough testing the lack
of testing was gonna kill us
that's all we heard the drumbeat from
the mainstream media from the left even
some people on the right told us this
for weeks and weeks and weeks now look
we got a ton of tests we have we have so
many tests that according to the
Washington Post we have too many tests
that's our new problem headline as
corona virus testing expands a new
problem arises not enough people to test
it took it took three reporters by the
way to write this piece four months into
the u.s. corona virus outbreak tests for
the virus finally are becoming widely
available finally Trump G's likely what
you couldn't get those tests out sooner
gosh we needed those tests which the
Washington Post describes is a crucial
step toward lifting stay at home
orders and safely returning to normal
life but while many states no longer
report crippling supply shortages a new
problem has emerged too few people
lining up to get tested so the the last
sentence of the article or the lessons
of a paragraph rather contradicts the
first sentences of the paragraph and the
whole premise hope the point whole point
is we need wide testing in order to lift
the lockdowns which by the way we don't
we can just lift the lockdown so you
just do it doesn't matter you don't need
to get permission from dr. fowey you are
a free people you are an elected
representative you can lift the lockdown
that you imposed but they tell us we
need the tests this is so important
people are clamoring waiting to get
tested and because we don't have the
tests we can't treat the virus oh wait a
minute nope got that one wrong - because
people aren't waiting to get tested
there there is an imaginary onrush of
people who need these tests but not not
a lot of imaginary people are able to
actually take the real test a Washington
Post survey of governor's offices and
state health department's found at least
a dozen states where testing capacity
outstrips the supply of patients oh my
gosh what what magnificently crafted
fake news that is look Washington Post
survey so it's a survey from the paper
that's reporting on this of governors
offices and state health department's
right forget the federal government here
is they hate Trump so much so anything
they anything good like having more
tests that can only be on the states you
can only give the state governors and
and health departments credit for that
at least a dozen states were testing
capacity outstrips the supply of
patients look at those words outstrips
and supply outstrips is the kind of word
that you hear when it's a bad thing like
it there's there's just too much and not
enough for that thing we're demanding
but the thing that we're demanding is
the supply of patients you don't want a
lot of patients when you're in an
epidemic you want a low number of
patients not a high knit but their
Washington Post is make
it seemed like you you oh if only we had
more patience if only we had more cases
and something tells me that is how they
really think one because it would have
justified their absurd hysterical order
of magnitude and then some too high
prediction models for the early doomsday
prophecies of coronavirus and two
because it would prevent Donald Trump
and others from reopening the country
and getting the economy going again and
keeping poor old Jo out of the White
House the number is well rising our well
short of capacity and far short of
targets set by independent experts those
independent experts in the lab coats
they want more coronavirus patients and
they're not getting them damn it and
they're really upset this is the
definition of a fake problem in LA by
the way we're seeing the results of a
policy made to address a fake problem
specifically on how the epidemic is
affecting the homeless we'll get to that
in one second first I've got to thank
our friends over at Rock Auto you know I
love Rock Auto the auto parts store the
old brick and mortar you ever noticed
that it never actually has what your car
needs and so you go there you say I need
the I don't know who's he who's he done
what's this the doohickey new dad I
don't know I don't know what car parts
are called and then they say oh no we
don't have that for your model so then
they go online probably to rockauto.com
then they order it and then the church
you double rockauto.com skip that step
it's family business serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years ago
rockauto.com to shop for auto and body
parts from hundreds of manufacturers
they've got everything you need from
engine control modules and brake parts
to tail lamps motor oil and even new
carpet and the website is so easy to
navigate even I can do it which is very
impressive stuff right now cut out that
middleman cut out the hassle especially
at a time like this where online makes
it a whole lot easier go to the guys
that I trust rockauto.com go there right
now see all the parts available for your
car or truck and then right Knolls KO
wles
in there how did you hear about us box
so that they will know that we sent you
over in LA they have clamored to address
a fake problem or at the very least we
could say they've created a very
inefficient solution to a real problem
that they haven't dealt with for decades
and that is the problem of homelessness
there are homeless people all over Los
Angeles when the mayor of Los Angeles
Eric Garcetti got elected he said he's
gonna deal with the homeless problem he
passes him I think with 1.8 billion
dollar bond or something like that don't
quote me exactly but a lot of money to
try to deal with the homeless problem
and the problem got worse not just a
little bit worse in that guy's first
year in office homelessness increased
16% 16% in one year it's all over the
place I mean if you if you go to
downtown LA I think the areas around
Skid Row the areas where like hunter
Biden hangs around it looks like you're
in a third world country
or even worse I mean it's even more
grotesque in a third world country
because you know that you're in this
land of prosperity and yet they're
tolerating this hope this actual tent
city in downtown LA you see that kind of
thing in Hollywood as well you see that
kind of thing in Brentwood and and
Beverly Hill well not as much Beverly
Hills but you see it in really nice
neighborhoods I mean huge tent cities
you know certain places in LA where they
have really a lot of local control like
Beverly Hills they have dealt with it so
it shows you the problem can be dealt
with but not in LA proper so you got all
these homeless people and then you've
got an epidemic yikes that doesn't sound
good especially if it's highly
contagious expected especially if it's
as deadly as all the experts told us it
was in the beginning which now appears
not to be true what were they gonna do
with the homeless people Li came up with
a plan the plan was to secure hotel
rooms for the homeless people of course
so you get them this is at a time when
people can't really afford to get their
own hotel rooms but instead if you don't
work and you hang out on the street and
you do drugs and you do whatever then
the city government is going to get you
hotel room so they they didn't just get
a few dozen hotel rooms few hundred
hotel rooms they got fifteen thousand
six hundred nineteen hotel rooms across
the state that's as of Monday it's the
project room key initiative from the
governor's office so not just not just
Los Angeles but also the state
government of those rooms do you know
how many are empty take a wild guess
about 50% of the 15,000 619 hotel rooms
77 hundred remain empty government's
paying for those so do you want the
government's not paying for anything you
are paying for those hotel rooms if you
live in Los Angeles or through the state
initiative California at all but it
remains totally empty because the
doomsday prediction models didn't come
true
homeless people willing to live on the
street heaven forfend that the
authorities go and say hey go to a
treatment center hey go to an asylum hey
go to prison if you're committing crimes
they would never do that they are
willing to put them up at the Ritz and
you know or maybe not quite as nice as
the Ritz but you get the idea and the
homeless people don't want to go and in
effective solution to a problem that was
way over predicted and then when they're
trying to make up for it when they're
trying to explain themselves and say
well yeah okay 2.2 million Americans
didn't die like the Imperial College
study said like the prediction models on
which we based our entire policy that
through 3040 million people out of work
yeah sure it didn't it didn't happen
and yeah the lockdowns didn't really do
much at all and yeah things are going
fine as people reopen they can't admit
that even though the facts make it
pretty clear they can't admit that so
look at this is like fake news par
excellence from the hill right the hill
website here's the headline Texas North
Carolina Arizona Rising cases as they
reopen now we know that some states are
reopening like Texas North Carolina
Georgia it's kind of funny that they
don't mention Georgia in here we know
that they do
Rising cases as they reopen so you got
one two three four five paragraphs
insinuating that there are all these
rising cases and it's because we're
reopening and really we should probably
lock down they're talking about the New
York Times only when you get down to the
sixth paragraph do you get the real news
story so here we go sixth paragraph one
reason for the increasing number of
cases in all three states is that they
are all seeing a significant rise in
testing which means more people carrying
kovat 19 are being identified that seems
like an important detail is things so
they're the reason that we're not
actually seeing more cases we're seeing
more positive results because there's
more testing don't you think you should
control for that like this this headline
is actually not true we have no evidence
that there are or that the cases are
rising we just know that the diagnoses
are rising because the testing is rising
don't you think all those lab code
experts might be able to control for
that sort of thing
I don't know next paragraph with more
testing we expect to see more cases
North Carolina's Health and Human
Services Secretary Mandy Cohen said
Monday at a news conference oh you
expected to see that because the
mainstream news media didn't expect to
see that apparently or maybe they did
they just wanted to fool us not all
states that are reopening or see
increased numbers of coronavirus cases
and there are significant variations
across the country as states move
forward with various phases of reopening
now you and I knew that you and I knew
that not all the states that are
reopening are seeing a spike in cases do
you know why because the first state
that they tried to make a big deal of
this in was Georgia
do you remember Georgia is the first
bold state they're gonna reopen we were
told there was going to be death and
carnage in the street it was gonna be
mayhem
those idiots those rubes oh just you
wait until and then it never happened
then it never happened and then it
passed out of the news I didn't even
have to check in to see how the death
toll and everything was going in Georgia
I didn't have to google it do you know
why because I knew that if things were
spiking over there in Georgia then
that would be the only news story
anyone's talking about that would be
24/7 CNN that would be all over the
Washington Post in the New York Times
the this is so sad
that you can now predict the media in
this way the fact that that story was
not in the newspaper was not on TV told
me everything I need it told me more
truth than had the reporters actually
been reporting on it then we finally got
they finally admitted here in the hill
Georgia one of the earliest states to
start reopening has not seen a spike in
cases and in fact had a slight decrease
Florida similarly has been mostly flat
Florida a state that did reopen barely
shut down and is full of old people it's
the state that old people go to ya know
spiked mostly flat so that hip about
that headline all three states all three
states that they're even talking about
are also not seeing problems with
hospital capacity a key metric you know
the reporting here is actually pretty
good you got a hand it to the hill for
reporting but those editors who write
those headlines seem to be contradicting
the reporting that happens throughout
the media and it's because the reality
has contradicted their insane prophecies
la now as a response to this is saying
that they're going to reopen sur la has
I mentioned keep mentioning la cuz
they've been the worst city on this
issue they've actually in the entire
country they have been the worst city on
managing this getting the numbers wrong
and getting the response wrong so they
said they were gonna keep us locked down
as everyone else is reopening they're
gonna keep us locked down until July now
they're saying well maybe it'll be early
July they're starting to reopen a little
bit sooner I have a message for Los
Angeles and for all of you we'll get to
that in a second we'll get to the bunk
bunk science before behind the lock
downs rather and then we'll get to Joe
Biden who says that we need a president
who believes in science I guess
apparently allegedly that's Joe Biden
first though I got to get to our friends
over at AB sleep you know it is very
important to get enough sleep every
night if you're having trouble falling
and staying asleep it's
time to try ab ab comfortably cools your
forehead helps quiet the racing mind and
promotes the natural onset of sleep the
minds normal way of dealing with stress
and stress stress stress and challenges
is to be on guard or more vigilant the
reverse of what's needed for a restful
night of sleep so what F does it's
actually very simple F has this cooling
calming nature that is designed to
interact with the way the mind body
reacts to stressful situations
allowing one to reach restorative sleep
quicker so that they can be at peak
performance the next day it's an amazing
feeling I've tried it on you put it on
your head and you immediately get this
very cooling sort of sensation that goes
through and it calms your thoughts and
it can help you sleep sleep understands
the uncertainty you may be experiencing
this time they want to help our
listeners can get 25 bucks off your
order by using promo code knowles canna
wles to save and continue to try
risk-free for 60 nights to confirm it's
the solution you've been looking for it
try EV calm / knowles let us help you
get the sleep you need remove the risk
from your purchase TR ye be be calm /
knowles try AB calm / Knowles promo code
Knowles to save order today if
everything going on you should get the
sleep that you need and deserve so la
announces they're gonna open a little
bit sooner supervisor Catherine Barger
for LA County says today the economic
resiliency task force met for the second
meeting and I set a goal to reopen LA
County by July 4th July 4th 4th read
more about our collaboration with sector
leaders to revitalize businesses and get
employees back to work blah blah blah I
don't care I don't care what these
people say I don't care what catherine
Barger says I don't care what Eric Carr
said he says I don't care what Gavin
Newsom says they're wrong they've been
wrong the whole time there they continue
to be wrong today I'm not going to
remain locked down until July or
whatever I don't care that you know
we've been saying this for a while now
and I think this is the point these
people can only lead us where we want to
go they are not dictators unless we
allow them to be dictators they're not
autocrats unless we allow them to be
autocrats
I look around Los Angeles the cars are
moving there's more traffic on the road
businesses are reopening whether the
city tells them they're allowed to or
not as a response to what people are
doing themselves the politicians now are
backing down because they know they got
nothing
they got absolutely nothing they got no
science on their side for one and we'll
get to that question in a second but -
you know they got to be re-elected and
they know that they're pretty unpopular
right now so I say we keep pushing that
on I'm not gonna wear a mask when I walk
when I go on a hike when I'm out in the
sunshine in the in the open air I'm not
going to stop working just not gonna do
it I'm I'm gonna ignore them I'm gonna
ignore Katherine Barger I'm going to
ignore Eric Garcetti obviously some of
these regulations you can't get over you
know you can't force a restaurant to
reopen but I strongly encourage
restaurants just reopen flout these
stupid orders based on nothing that have
now transparently become arbitrary power
grabs by feckless politicians who are
simply trying to maintain the illusion
that they've got power over you just
ignore it it's if they had credibility
we would listen to them they don't so
that's my that's my opinion on this
issue
how could I be clearer about it I'm not
sure it's already effectively over
that's the thing at least here I don't
know I guess it varies city by city
state by state
according to Apple mobility trends we
are quickly approaching pre kovat levels
in terms of driving and walking so I'm
not saying like I know it sounds like
I'm rallying the troops and I'm saying
we have to go out there and fight the
powers and I'm not even saying that I'm
simply saying the politicians don't have
credibility and so people are ignoring
them and they want to continue to ignore
them you can see it from the mobility
trends when you look at you know the
trends that Apple is measuring on
people's cell phones for where they're
walking how much they're moving around
that number plummeted at the beginning
of the lockdown now it's just creeping
back up again same with driving that's
that's not even prescriptive that's
descriptive and that's a good thing
effectively we are getting out of this
how did we lock down in the first place
this this is amazing and no one is
talking about it because it's so
embarrassing
the American Institute for Economic
Research I just published this piece
which genius scientist with a big gray
beard and a lab coat who has degrees
from Harvard and MIT and which one do
you think gave us the idea for a
lockdown oh it wasn't any of them it was
a 14-year old high school girl yes
the idea for the lockdown as a response
to the epidemic came to us not from the
exalted dr. fowey not from the are
amazing soothsayer scientific priestly
class not even from the elected
politicians as a 14 year old high school
girl 14 year old high school girl who
was the daughter of a scientist at
Sandia National Laboratories she devised
a computer simulation that showed how
people family members co-workers
students and schools people and social
situations interact so she builds the
computer model she discovered that
school kids come in contact with about
140 people a day which is more than any
other group based on that finding her
program showed that in a hypothetical
town of 10,000 people 5,000 would become
infected during a pandemic if no
measures were taken but only 500 would
be infected if the schools were closed
according to this high school girls
computer model the girls name which I
won't say because it's not her fault
that we created an international policy
based on a 14 year old girls science
model is I'm not not going to say her
name but her name does appear on the
foundational paper arguing for lock
downs enforced human separation that
paper is the targeted social distancing
designs for pandemic influenza from 2006
you know what this story reminds me of
this reminds me exactly of how we got
the band
on plastic straws that's another
hysteria that has caught on around the
country if not around the world would
you remember back in the olden days of
like six months ago we used to have
plastic straws that we could use when we
would drink out of cups and then one day
they banned the straws for some reason
we had to use those stupid paper straws
that just turn into pulp and you have to
eat them how did that happen
was it because some scientist in a big
lab coat with a big gray beard who's you
know really super smart and educated
told us that we had to do it know was it
from some elected politicians
imagination no there's a nine-year-old
boy nine-year-old boy fourth grade boy
who did a school project tried to
estimate how many plastic straws people
use every day called a few companies
tried to extrapolate from there and then
started a non-profit activist movement
to try to get people to not use straws
and then when that didn't work to try to
get the straws banned not based on
science you know science with a capital
S and a trademark over the not based on
the guys in the lab coat it's not even
based on the ethical and political
discussions among our elected
representatives and among ourselves no
fourth-grade boy that's the kind of
science that we see all around here and
that's the kind of science that the Left
believes in including Joe Biden who says
we need a president who believes in
science we'll get to that in a second
first though I've got to thank our
friends over at liquid ivy now is not
the time to let your body get dehydrated
you need to stay healthy okay and liquid
ivy is an easy healthy solution for
dehydration one stick of liquid ivy in
16 ounces of water hydrates you faster
and more efficiently than water alone if
you're dehydrated try liquid IV it's the
fastest most efficient way to stay
hydrated proper hydration is crucial for
your immune system it can boost your
immunity liquid Ivy's got more vitamin C
than an orange as much potassium as a
banana packed with vitamins b3 b5 b6 and
b12 vitamins known to help your body
defend against infections that might be
helpful right now huh liquid IV in a
16-ounce a glass of water can give
as much hydration is two to three
bottles of plain water a really great
stuff obviously it's used a lot for like
athletes and things like that it's not
exactly me but if you have a cup of
cocoa colas with the boys as some people
have been doing lately even over the
Internet
liquid IV can help you feel a little bit
better on that - like what IVs available
nationwide at Target Whole Foods and
Costco or you can get 25% off when you
go to liquid IV calm and use code
Michael mi CH AE L at checkout 25% off
anything you order when use promo code
Michael at liquid IV comm get better
hydration today liquid IV com promo code
Michael and you can find them at Target
Whole Foods for Costco a lot of science
that doesn't seem particularly
scientific and that's the science that
the left wants us to believe in Joe
Biden tweets out we need a president who
believes in science now you know we
actually have a clause in our
Constitution that prevents there being a
religious test for people to hold office
and the way that Joe Biden is talking
about science the way that the left is
implementing science is religious it's
fundamentally religious it's not based
even on the premises of this very narrow
understanding of natural science of the
last few hundred years it isn't based on
that the way that they talk about it the
way that the LA County Supervisor and
everybody else they say we're gonna
reopen o magic o magic crystal ball
we're gonna reopen on July 4th so long
as science and data tell us that it is
ok yes the all-mighty science and data
are letting me know that exactly on July
4th we are allowed to leave our homes
again and have an economy and have a
politics where we debate issues thank
you praise be to you peace upon you
science and data the science and data
that basis international policy and a
fourth grade boys science project a few
phone calls that he made we're sort of
science and data that begins with a 14
year old girls experiment 14 year old
girls model then the models turn out not
to be so great that's the science that
we're talking about
I I think we need to we need to ban the
word science we can't use that word
science anymore because it doesn't mean
it's it's not a useful word because the
way the left uses it is in a religious
sense the way the right uses it is in a
modern scientific sense you know in that
very narrow way of an empirical inquiry
and that sort of thing but even that
doesn't get to it the word science
refers to the word for knowledge the way
that science is used throughout history
is it includes philosophy it includes
natural investigations it includes all
knowledge when one group tries to argue
and say we have the knowledge and no one
else has the knowledge that that is not
very helpful in our politics
okay presumably we can look at knowledge
and we can have debates and the way that
the Left uses science is to shut down
the bate debate and to say that the
expert in the lab code is going to make
all of our decisions for us and he just
happens to agree with us and so that's
gonna be our science to say nothing of
the obvious problems with a group
claiming to believe in science and then
denying the humanity of little babies
and pretending that boys are really
girls and girls are really boys and
there are 56 other genders as well it's
just not a useful term and we should all
step using speaking of unuseful terms
stupid terms coming out of Joe Biden Joe
Biden has a new nickname for President
Trump it's pretty pretty lame we'll get
to that in a second
we will also get to the way that Trump
is responding both to Joe Biden and to
Nancy Pelosi then a shocking deathbed
confession from Norma McCorvey the woman
who is Jane Roe and Roe versus Wade or
is it shocking I don't know we'll get to
that just a moment but first I've got to
thank you and remind you by the way that
we're gonna be doing backstage
remember those Wednesday May 27 7 p.m.
Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific and it's time to
share even better news even better the
double tumbler is back remember a few
weeks ago and you signed up you get two
tumblers not just one but two it's
dumped double as good then it went away
but now it's available except it's only
available for our most exclusive
membership tier all
says you get everything you get two more
hours of ben shapiro show exclusive Q&A
is new all access live shows you know
which is not really even a show it's
more of a hangout you get double the
tumblers that's very important do I have
my second I do it my second tumbler here
good I'm gonna need it when we get to
the Joe Biden bit head on over to Daley
wire.com slash subscribe join all-access
get 15% off with coupon code Knowles
right now daily wire.com / subscribe
coupon code Knowles see you right there
we'll be right back
Joe Biden has a nickname for Donald
Trump you thought Trump had good
nicknames or wait'll you hear Joe's
nickname for the president I fail to get
this money out to the folks who
desperately needed to stay afloat is it
incompetence corruption Trump is out
there tweeting again this morning icon
president Tweedy reopened the country
end of quote how are we supposed to do
that if you're sitting on the money
small businesses need in order to stay
alive stop tweeting about it get the
money out to Main Street now is there
it's been passed this pandemic is
hitting everyone hard we need serious
competent leadership now more than ever
President Tweety I call him president
Tweety yeah it took me till we got three
years to think of that one but I think
it's pretty good I think it's I'm gonna
send it in to Bob Hope see if he uses
the joke president Tweety
that's very lame that's not a good
nickname you know Donald Trump came up
with some of the best nicknames in
recent political memory right you had
low-energy Jeb little Marco or you had
the crook crooked Hillary was a stroke
of genius crooked Hillary totally nailed
her sleepy Joe another stroke of genius
at the time a lot of people said mr.
president why aren't you gonna call him
creepy Joe because they were all talking
about a Joe would smell people's hair
and stuff now that wasn't as good the
attack on Joe Biden is not that Joe
Biden is some secret villainous
mastermind pedophile no that's not it
it's that he is a senile and doddering
man who even in his prime wasn't
particularly smart wasn't particularly
with it that's the attack it's a much
more effective attack you can see the
Trump campaign leaning into this even
more in really creative ways Trump
campaign just released an ad it's sort
of an ad I guess it's produced by the
Trump campaign and it's a sort of mock
you know true crime show that's just
making fun of all those sad senile
aspects of Joe my name is Joe Biden I'm
a Democratic candidate
United States Senate crock-pot was a bad
seed be the oldest president American
history
are you in church
thank you very much it's Chris but
anyway and 20 million back in the
workforce we choose choose over fax
hello and welcome to the first episode
of what we call truth over fax today
we're examining the curious case of
sleepy Joe and you know the thing our
investigation begins at a recent
campaign stop in Texas join us next time
when we will work with a renowned sketch
artist who will reveal who or what is a
lying dog faced pony soldier oh man what
a great what a great series I hope there
really are more of these it plays it
plays to so many important points one
Trump and the Trump campaign certainly
gets the country okay do you remember a
few weeks ago there was the Lincoln
project as a group of disgruntled former
Republicans who hate Donald Trump and
conservatism apparently any conservative
policies and so they they ran this big
ad campaign called morning in America
but it's mo u RN ing knows it's Donald
Trump is really bad it's morning in
America he's really bad don't vote for
Trump Trump you know it just it seemed
like an ad from 90s TV not like an ad
from 2020 digital culture well this is
the opposite of that right Tripp what
what the Trump campaign realizes is that
stuff's so dated it's so played out
people want to be entertained a little
bit they don't want this to be a scary
ad they don't want it to Club them over
the head they want it to entertain them
a little bit Ronald Reagan was very good
at entertaining people Donald Trump very
good at entertaining people and
true-crime just to say Shawn revenge
attainment is is almost certainly the
most popular one in the whole country
when you look at podcasts true-crime
shoots to the top of the charts people
love those true crime shows and so it's
a mock true crime show making fun of Joe
Biden your look no one's afraid of Joe
Biden so
none of our foes around the world but no
one in the United States ones afraid of
Joe Biden okay they can say oh yeah he's
creepy with women and okay whatever no
nobody we've known Joe for a long time
it's fine he's and now he's a sort of
frail older gentleman so really no one's
afraid the real attack is he's a joke
make him into a joke and laugh at him
it's gonna have a much much more
damaging effect on him in 2020 so that's
how he goes after Biden he goes after in
a similar way Nancy Pelosi even off the
cuffs you remember the other day Nancy
Pelosi referred to Donald Trump is
morbidly obese in this gratuitous
comment on a television show
so Trump was asked about that and he he
just swatted her away I don't respond to
her I think she's a waste of time these
people are sick Pelosi is a sick woman
she's got a lot of problems a lot of
mental problems we're dealing with
people that have to get their act
together for the good of the country
okay thank you very much I like this I
like this kind of response I mean I wish
we lived in a time it would be much
better if we lived in a time where
people had civility and grace and just
sort of really witty repartee
we don't okay we don't that's not the
time that we live in we're not going to
have sort of Churchillian zingers going
back and forth necessarily or
some kind of really elevated speech this
is the kind of world we're living in and
if we're living in this world I want
Donald Trump to be on my side Nancy
Pelosi called you fed oh yeah I think
she's crazy now it seems like a tit for
tat but it's not really because what
Pelosi did was go for this kind of
physical issue that Trump has that a lot
of people have namely being a little
overweight who do you know that isn't a
little overweight is America for
goodness sake everybody's a little bit
overweight so that doesn't play as well
you go for a physical thing that
describes virtually everybody what Trump
does is then go for a mental thing the
mint which doesn't describe everybody
know very few people in this country are
as crazy as Nancy Pelosi
but he goes for that mental thing
because that is psychological that is
what is that is using your faculties of
reason that is what we're really doing
when we engage in politics right we're
dealing with issues the leaders of this
country are using their minds and their
brains hopefully to guide ourselves
doesn't matter what they look like
necessarily Winston Churchill was a big
fat guy too so I know and I don't think
that that was like a real knock against
him and so I think Trump is focusing on
the more important thing here now what
that means into 2020 who knows I think
that the left knows that they're really
not looking good Pelosi is not playing
well Joe Biden certainly not playing
well so you're gonna hear a lot more
shenanigans about mail and voting
they're gonna probably try to minimize
the conventions and Republicans would be
crazy to let them do it we should have a
big showing for these conventions we
should make sure people show up to vote
because I think when people are engaging
with the reality of this campaign in the
reality of voting you know real real
life in person I don't think it's gonna
go very well for the left big story
maybe a big story they say it's a big
story I don't know that it's a big story
Norma McCorvey
who is Jane Roe in Roe vs. Wade
Norma McCorvey was this woman who was
kind of used by the pro-abortion
industry and then in the mid 1990s she
became pro-life she became a pro-life
advocate she was born again you know
described herself as an evangelical
Christian there's now they're now saying
that she had a deathbed confession that
it was all a lie she didn't really
become pro-life she I guess she didn't
really become Christian it's unclear
from the trailer of the movie and she
really just got she just did it for the
money you know they got a lot of gifts
from the pro-life movement and so she
just did it for the money they bought
her off they paid her to do it that's
the claim in the mainstream media we
don't know the movies not out yet
I watched the trailers you know there's
nothing in the trailers that suggests
that she really does recant her pro-life
or Christian views so I'm skeptical in
the first place then I look at the
people that the film is talking to the
film considers an ex-pro life now
pro-abortion anti-christian pastor named
Rob Schenck
to be an expert on this issue so already
I'm looking at that I say okay this
movie does not have a lot of credibility
seems like this is mostly hype to
promote the movie if I were a film
producer I know a lot of film producers
have been in Hollywood a little while
this is the sort of thing you do to
garner attention get some headlines try
to get people to pay for your movie and
they don't they don't quite really give
you anything in the trailer so it's just
like every other movie you know the best
stuff they got is in the trailer and
then you see the movie and it's kind of
disappointing I suspect that's the same
thing going on here the articles that
are coming out about this don't really
explain certain things if it was all an
act if it was all an act
why did Norma McCorvey who had a lesbian
girlfriend why did she break up with her
lesbian girlfriend upon her conversion
you know and this girlfriend gave you
know pretty raw interviews of being
really really an anguish about this
whole situation so why did she do that
that that doesn't really make a lot of
sense why why did she do it for the
money presumably she could have gotten
more money from the pro-abortion groups
right the pro-abortion groups are are
way better funded in this country then
the pro-life groups are so why didn't
she just stick with her original team
and what does that even mean to be paid
off today you know flyer around the
country and you know bring her to speak
at places okay is that really a payoff I
don't know I just it doesn't really seem
that compelling to me that convincing to
me and we also we have video you know we
got it on tape of Jane Rowe at least
number of years ago describing why she
became pro-life most of you won't
recognize me or my real name it's Norma
McCorvey I'm also known as Jane Roe the
plaintiff in the Supreme Court case Roe
vs. Wade which legalized abortion in
America and changed our nation in an
unprecedented way back in 1973 I was
very confused 21 year old
with one child and facing an unplanned
pregnancy at the time I fought to obtain
a legal abortion but the truth be told I
have three daughters and have never had
an abortion however upon knowing God I
realized that my case which legalized
abortion on demand was the biggest
mistake of my life
you see abortion has eliminated 50
million innocent babies in the u.s.
lungs since 1973 abortion scar is an
untold number of post abortive mothers
fathers and families too you read about
being history books but now I'm
dedicated to spreading the truth about
preserving the dignity of all human life
from natural conception to natural death
so pretty convincing I guess she could
have been putting on an act there for
you know I don't think there's a ton of
money in it but maybe she could have I
don't know my takeaway from this is who
cares the left is presenting this as
though here we go now the pro-life
movement is on the ropes the pro-life
movement is dead it's all a sham what
are you talking about I don't think this
hurts the pro-life movement at all in
any way if it's if it's not true if this
is all just hype to sell this movie and
they're misrepresenting what she really
said then you know it's typical lies
from the pro-abortion movement if it is
true if she really did have a deathbed
confession that says her whole pro-life
advocacy was a big sham then Norma
McCorvey is a liar and who cares anyway
who cares what she says if she was lying
then she might be lying now or she's
lying now she might have been lying then
if she repented great if not then you
know we're no worse off than where we
started if she lied and and if now she's
giving this confession that was all a
big sham I'm still glad that pro-lifers
gave her the benefit of the doubt I'm
still glad and if the end if she got
some honorariums or she got you know
flown around the country or something
I'm glad she did she's obviously a
damaged woman who was used by the
pro-abortion movement abortion itself
uses Church destroys people so if she
said she had any inclination that she
was going to switch over I'm glad we
gave her the benefit of the doubt
even if she lied to everybody because
there are still many many other very
prominent abortions
who became pro-life even if Norma
McCorvey didn't or if she did but then
she went back or even if it was
complicated okay there's still so many
others who were so clear about this I
think of dr. Bernard Nathanson founder
of nay RAL you know the biggest abortion
rights organization in the country
Bernard Nathanson was a doctor
abortionist who became vehemently
pro-life because he saw the reality of
it and he he admitted that the the
pro-abortion movement lied a lot Abby
Johnson another great example Abby
Johnson worked to Planned Parenthood was
very much involved in the reality of
abortion has now become a major major
pro-life advocate why cuz she saw the
reality of it in fact you know if Norma
McCorvey never never did or if she did
have this deathbed confession or what
not one explanation of that is that she
never had an abortion if she says I've
never had an abortion myself I was not
able to get an abortion before that
court case well I would explain it
because the huge Pro former pro-abortion
a pro-life advocates the the ones who
became most clearly pro-life are the
ones who had most clearly seen the
reality of abortion you know it's there
just so many people who've gone from the
pro-abortion direction to the pro-life
direction very few people have gone the
other way around I mean he's just even
I'm in my own anecdotally I myself when
I was a teenager I thought abortion made
perfect sense I didn't I didn't I didn't
understand the objection you know I grew
up in a secular kind of culture I would
have called myself an atheist or an
agnostic I just thought I don't see what
the big deal is then I had a
conversation with a bio ethicist and she
convinced me and I saw I just just
through argumentation I sort of saw the
problem at the heart of abortion I saw
the reality of it then obviously over
time my thinking deepened certainly on
the nature of human life and human
dignity and and now I look back and I
see I realized there's no argument at
all for abortion other than this kind of
selfishness and materialism that we're
all steeped in in the pop culture so I
you know I I hope Norma McCorvey for her
own sake was not a liar all those years
and a and a secret defender of abortion
but you know if she was that's too bad
and the movement the movement moves on
with the people who who know the reality
of it before we go I just have to get to
this this is this is the funniest story
I so I think that this actually
tickled me the most from the New York
Times we talked yesterday or the day
before about Tesla and about how Elon
Musk
took the red pill so he says you know it
think for yourself question the liberal
narrative right so the headline is Tesla
owners try to make sense of a Elon
Musk's red pill moment they're trying to
make sense of it they want they're gonna
wear it go return their cars because now
Elon Musk might not be a total
dyed-in-the-wool liberal his politics
might be slightly complicated because
he's questioning the liberal narrative
you know the the best part of this whole
Elon Musk thing is it tricked a bunch of
liberals who bought electric cars which
frankly gave me some ideas I thought
maybe we should now convince the left
that those paper straws was really
frustrating paper drinking straws the
turnip pulp that they're actually a
neo-nazi hate symbol so that we can get
those banned and go back to the plastics
for us okay give me a lot of different
ideas but that was the basic point was
they found out that Elon Musk's politics
were not totally liberal and therefore
they they got to ditch the car if you
think Tesla's are problematic just wait
until you hear about Ford's just wait
until you I apparently people don't know
this about Henry Ford Henry Ford had
some problematic politics you might say
particularly when it regards that
certain nomadic tribe ancient tribe
known as the Jews Henry Ford published a
four-volume work called the
International Jew book one of that is
the International Jew the world's
foremost problem Baldur von Schirach
one of the Nazi leaders said this is
what he said of Henry Ford's book I read
it and became anti-semitic in those days
of this book made such a deep impression
on my friends and myself because we saw
in Henry Ford the representative of
success also the exponent of a
progressive social policy Henry Ford was
the only American mentioned in meine
Kampf mentioned glowingly Hitler himself
writes every year makes them referring
to the Jews
more and more the controlling masters of
the producers in a nation of a hundred
and twenty million persons only a single
great man Ford to their fury still
maintains full independence so you know
Henry Ford he's got some baggage here
right and people still buy Ford cars
that is to the broader point on the
Tesla's something perhaps we should say
to the left the personal views the
politics of people who create products
or who write great works of literature
who great great works of art who cares
it's kind of my same reaction to the
last tour we were talking about I don't
I don't care I don't know Henry Ford
Henry Ford doesn't mean anything to me
I like Ford cars I think Mustangs look
cool fine
Arthur Kessler was a great great
novelist wrote one of the one of the
great anti-communist novelists of all
time darkness at noon he was I think a
pretty credibly accused of rape didn't
seem like such a great guy some of the
great I mean we know this just from
celebrities all around us a lot of
celebrities whose work we really enjoy
are dirty rotten no-good terrible people
for most of the history of art we've
just ignored that sort of thing because
we don't really care but now we've
become in this so highly sensitive just
seeking to be offended by anything and
outraged by anything culture that forget
Arthur casts there forget Henry Ford
forget all these people now just because
Elon Musk suggests maybe he's not a
total progressive liberal totally 100
percent of the time the New York Times
is publishing stories about how people
don't want their Tesla cars anymore
that is a trigger-happy culture that is
a culture that would appear to have too
few problems that's our show
I'm Michael Knowles as the my gonna show
you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director Pavel
madoski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson hair and makeup Nika Geneva
production assistant Ryan love the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin hosted
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]